CHADE-MENG TAN: Good afternoon
my friends.
So in 2007 we started a program
called "Search Inside
Yourself," and as we were
looking around the room we
decided that we needed somebody
very special.
So, to create this class, or
to bring this class to the
next level, let's look for a
business leader, an executive.
Let's look for somebody with
10,000 hours of meditation
training and is a respected
meditation teacher; and has
experience running
a business--
a successful business;
preferably a CEO--
preferably a founding CEO; and
preferably is a top leader;
preferably an author of business
books; and has an
MBA; and is willing
to work with us.
So, hmm.
Does this person even
exist in the world?
And we were very fortunate
that we found him, Marc,
today's guest.
And he was right there.
Because we had already started
working with him as a
coach at that time.
And it was, this is it.
He's the guy we've
been looking for.
So we're very lucky
to have him, Marc.
And Marc is here to talk about
his book, [INAUDIBLE].
This book, his third book,
and in my opinion
his best book yet.
And this is a book about
paradoxes, except it is not,
paradoxically.
[LAUGHTER]
And it's about paradoxes leading
you to a happier, more
successful life.
And with that, my friend
Marc Lesser.
[APPLAUSE]
MARC LESSER: Thank
you and welcome.
Someone just asked me,
what's the meaning?
Or where did they come up with
the title of this book, "Know
Yourself, Forget Yourself." I
had to admit that I stole the
title from the words of
a 13th century Zen
teacher named Dogen.
Actually Dogen was the founder
of Zen in Japan, and a very
prolific, very wonderful
teacher.
And one of his most known
expressions, in fact it's so
well known that I once
published it
as a greeting card--
I used to run a publishing
company that
made greeting cards.
And this quote by Dogen says "to
study the way is to study
the self; to study the self is
to forget the self and to
forget the self is to awaken, or
to become enlightened with
everything and everyone." And I
first heard that expression
probably about 40 years ago,
and I've been mulling that
expression for much
of my life.
What does it mean?
What does it mean to
study yourself?
know yourself?
What does it mean and how does
that lead to self knowing?
And how does that lead to
becoming someone who can be
truly effective, influential
and powerful in the world?
I want to start with a Zen
story, one of my favorite Zen
stories, which is
about a funeral.
This is a story about these two
Zen teachers who decide to
go to a, they're going
to a funeral.
And they get there early,
and they noticed that
no one else is there.
And they see a coffin, a coffin
that has the body of
the deceased friend of theirs.
And you never know what to
expect when you get the Zen
guys together.
So these two Zen teachers go
walking, they go right up to
the coffin.
And one of them raps his
hand on the coffin,
knocks on the coffin.
Imagine if you were one
of these people.
And he looks at the
other teacher and
says "alive or dead?
Alive or dead?" And the other
teacher, without hesitating,
looks at him and says "I won't
say, I won't say." So this is
a story about the things we take
for granted, about what
does it mean to be alive.
What does it mean to be a
fully alive human being?
And what is this thing that
we call life and death?
And that it's a paradox.
Everything about being a human
being, I think when we stop to
look a little bit more
carefully and more
closely, is a paradox.
So breathing in and
breathing out.
So I sometimes when I'm teaching
meditation, and maybe
we can all practice this a
little bit even while we're
right here, so breathing in
is a kind of self knowing;
breathing in, kind of know some
sense of what's happening.
What's happening with
you right now?
What are you feeling?
Who are you?
What do you think it
means to be you?
And as you breathe out,
letting it go.
Like just forgetting,
forgetting it all.
Completely refreshing,
completely refreshing
yourself; that you can actually
use the breath and do
this with every breath.
So it's self knowing and self
forgetting, self knowing and
self forgetting.
As I was writing this book, this
book came as somewhat of
a surprise to me.
My last book was called "Less.
Accomplishing More by Doing
Less." I signed a contract to
write another book.
And the contract I signed
was to write a book
called "More", obviously.
Because I felt like a lot of
people had, a lot of people
liked "Less", but every once in
awhile I would meet CEOs of
companies who would say, "I
really love this book "Less".
You've done such a great job,
but I'm not giving it to any
of my employees because I don't
want them doing less."
And I realized he totally
didn't get it.
"Less" isn't about doing less.
Less is about getting more done
by being more effective,
more present.
And that was the beginning
of thinking I need to
straighten this out.
I need to write a book that is
clear about, that it needs to
be a book about more.
So I signed this contract for
a book called "More."
And I started down this
road of writing
a book called "More".
And what kept coming
up for me was how
paradoxical everything was.
That everything about my life,
when I looked at my life as a
business person, as someone who
was working in the world
as an executive coach, as a
CEO, as someone who was
working with business people,
and at the same time I'm also
a Zen teacher.
I thought, just that.
How paradoxical is that?
Just my own definitions
of myself.
But all of the work, when I felt
like I'd be in front of a
CEO of a company, what kept
coming up for me was working
in the realm of paradox.
How do you actually practice
with things like confidence
and questioning?
How do you actually work with
things like fighting for
change and accepting what is?
I noticed even just
those two themes--
being confident and questioning
everything,
fighting for change and
accepting what is.
Those two paradoxes I've noticed
were mainstays of my
coaching practice as well as
my Zen teaching practice.
And then there was this
emotional paradox about, over
and over again as I work in the
realm of teaching people
about emotional intelligence, it
became clear that the idea
wasn't about tamping down
one's emotions.
In fact, the practice is about
becoming completely free in
your own emotional life.
Learning to trust your emotions,
and be a completely
emotional being and at the same
time to find a sense of
equanimity.
So this became another core
paradox, was embrace emotion
and embody equanimity.
And then this other paradox kept
coming up about, wait a
minute-- do we take
care of ourselves?
How do we take care
of ourselves?
What does real well-being
practice mean?
What does it mean to eat well
and exercise and really take
good care of ourselves, and at
the same time I thought that
our lives were supposed to be
about benefiting others.
So this became another one of
these core paradoxes, the
paradox of benefit others
and benefit yourself.
So one morning as this book was
starting to take shape, I
remember one morning in
particular, I was getting up
at about 3:00 or 3:30
AM to write.
Because at one point it just
really grabbed me, the subject
about paradox and how to bring
paradox into the world, and
how important it is to actually
identify, embrace and
practice with paradox.
So this book is about the
importance and practices for
how to, not only not push away
paradox, but how to embody it,
embrace it, and how to practice
with paradox.
That the practice of paradox,
I think, might be one of the
most important and core
practices for human beings.
And one morning as I sat down to
write, I noticed I started
to feel agitated and
almost angry.
And I found myself writing I
don't want this book to be
about paradox.
I don't like paradox.
I want this book to
be about clarity.
And I want to read you, this is
partly what when I started
to write that morning.
Personally speaking I'm not
happy or satisfied with the
idea of paradox.
I don't really want this book
to be about paradox.
I want this book to
be about clarity.
Who wants paradoxical
relationships
or paradox in business?
We all want confidence
and assurance.
Imagine a stockbroker, surgeon,
or soldier using the
word paradox to describe
his or her work.
Paradox seems to be the
opposite of clarity.
The opposite of action.
A non-answer.
Perhaps a shrug.
In my work life and personal
life I've come to realize that
embracing what is obvious
is not always so easy.
Meanwhile paradox can point
to a radical clarity.
My hope is that this book will
help you see that with paradox
comes a kind of clarity that is
more accurate, more true,
more clear than clear.
I see that as I was writing
this, that line really
surprised me.
That with paradox comes the kind
of clarity that is more
accurate, more true, more clear
than clear, than what we
usually accept at face value.
Life and death are a paradox.
In our day-to-day lives we're
constantly torn between
opposites and duality, between
competing desires and needs.
There is no escaping
the paradoxical
nature of the world.
If we accept this and meet
paradox head on, if we work
with and penetrate these
apparently unsolvable
conundrums, the place
we reach is insight.
I was remembering when I was
a young Zen student--
just a brief part about
my own story--
I took a one-year leave of
absence from Rutgers when I
was a psychology student there
and came out to the West
Coast, and then spent 10 years
living at the San Francisco
Zen Center.
So that one year turned
into 10 years.
And, as you might imagine and I
can see it now, now that I'm
a parent, that this wasn't
really what my parents had in
mind for me.
And in particular my father was
quite upset with me for
having dropped out of college
and spent all these years
living at the San Francisco
Zen Center.
I think it was right in the
midst of that, maybe my fourth
or fifth year at the Zen Center
I got a call one day
from my mother, saying that my
father was quite ill, that my
father had cancer and
was in the hospital.
And I immediately, at this
time I was living at Zen
Center's Green Gulch farm in
Marin, a and I stopped doing
the work that I was doing, which
was working with horses,
learning how to farm
with horses.
And I got on a plane and flew to
New Jersey where I grew up.
And I discovered that my father
was quite ill, that he
had been highly, highly drugged,
and was so confused
at night that they had to tie
him down in order for him not
to be wandering around
the hospital.
And I discovered that no one had
let him know at all what
was happening, and that he was
completely, completely confused.
And fortunately I had some
really, really amazing
resources and support system
at the Zen Center, so that
when I arrived at the hospital,
my support system,
this group of older women
mentors, Zen teachers, they
told me that it just
looked like the
doctors were in charge.
That actually I was in charge
and that I could take control
of the situation.
I could have them stop giving my
father drugs, I could untie
him, and I could actually have a
real conversation and let my
father know just what was
happening with him.
And I was so grateful and moved
that I had that kind of
support system and was
able to do that.
So I was 26 at the time.
And I can remember after taking
my father off drugs,
untying him, and having a
conversation in which I let
him know that he was quite ill
and in fact he might be, it
looked, the doctors thought
that he didn't have
very long to live.
That he was dying of cancer, and
at the same time that one
never knows actually what will
happen, and I wanted to keep
some hope alive.
And my father looked at me and
said that he had been so angry
with my choices.
But he had no idea what I was
doing at the Zen Center, but
whatever it was I was doing,
he was really, really happy
and proud of me.
And I was able to meet my father
in a way, in the most
intimate and powerful way that
I had in my entire life.
And this was a huge--
I had no idea that I had changed
or that I was any
different than I was, but it was
so amazing and powerful to
see, through my father's
eyes, the changes that
I had made in myself.
And I feel like this is, in a
way, at the heart of knowing
yourself and forgetting
yourself.
Practicing over and over again
this self knowledge and self
forgetting.
I'm sitting here looking at my
good friend Meng who created,
was the inspiration for the
Search Inside Yourself program
here at Google.
And I was just remembering Meng
and I taught together
many, many times, and I've
taught with other people as
well with the Search Inside
Yourself program.
And one day I was driving
down to Google.
We were about to teach
an all-day day
of mindfulness together.
And I noticed as I was
driving I was feeling
more and more anxiety.
I was remembering that everyone
at Google who is in
the class was going to rate me
on a scale of one to five
about how my performance was.
And I noticed every time I got
these ratings my eye would go,
I would actually say who gave
me a bad, who gave me a one,
how many ones or
twos did I get.
And it didn't even seem to
matter if I got mostly fives.
That I couldn't help but notice
how much effect it had
on me, those negative
assessments.
And as I was driving down, I
noticed myself feeling more
and more upset and anxious and
not wanting to be there.
And I happened to, I looked next
to me and I had some CDs.
I had a CD by the poet, this
wonderful poet, who I'm sure
many of you know-- if you
don't, you should--
David White.
I put in a CD by the poet
David White, and he was
talking about the importance
of embracing paradox.
And the importance of finding
your own edge, and trusting
yourself no matter what might
be happening in your life.
And at some point I said
to myself, I'm just
going to show up.
I'm just going to completely
show up for that class.
I don't care how
they grade me.
It doesn't matter.
And I walked in to that room,
and Meng and I started
teaching that class together.
And I think it was like at the
break in the morning, Meng
turned to me and said what
happened to you?
That there was a way that
I felt really freed.
And I think part of my own
freedom was recognizing that I
felt my own feeling of
being an impostor.
And I think the more and more
we put ourselves out there,
the more successful we are, the
more we're able to do what
we actually want to do, I
think it's more and more
important that we recognize that
we all have some version
of that anxiety and doubt, and
maybe even feeling like a
complete impostor.
And I think this is part of this
paradox of be confident,
question everything.
And I think the more we can
question, the more we can go
deeper and deeper to
find ourselves.
And the more that we can go
deeper and deeper, the more
confident we feel.
And at the same time, the more
and more confident we feel,
invariably, over and over again,
more and more questions
arise about what really
is our motivation.
That we're all so much of our
human lives and our human--
human life is about
relationship, and relationship
seems to be about conflict
and paradox.
That we even feel, so much so
that we even feel conflict
within ourselves.
Do we accept what is, or
do we fight for change?
And the answer to that is yes.
Yes, we have to completely
practice accepting what is,
and at the same time,
we need to practice
fighting for change.
And I like to call, and actually
this was an idea that
I got from reading some books
by Peter Senge, in which he
talks about creative tension
and the importance of being
able to stay with and embrace
creative tension.
And I think I didn't like so
much calling it tension, so I
call it in my book
creative gaps.
And a creative gap is
identifying and recognizing
where you are now and where
you want to be.
And this can be with a
particular project.
So like, all of you, I'm sure,
have maybe tens or 50 or
hundreds of creative
gaps in your life.
What are the projects?
What are the things that you're
working on in which, if
you look where are you now and
where do you want to be in
that project?
We also have big life
creative gaps.
Where are you in your life right
now, and where do you
want to be?
We have these emotional
creative gaps.
In what way, what are some
particular, maybe we want to
cultivate more joy.
Maybe we want to cultivate
more kindness.
Maybe we want to cultivate more
compassion in our lives.
So just starting with accepting
where you are now,
how much joy, how much kindness,
how much compassion
is there in your
life right now?
And where do you want to be, and
what do you need to do to
actually get there?
So this is an example of
accepting what is and fighting
for change at the same time.
I think I want to
try something.
I want to get you all talking a
little bit about describing
yourselves a bit as a paradox.
And I want to do this
in two ways.
One is I'm going to ask
you to think about how
you might be a paradox.
And I also want to ask people to
take a little bit of a risk
here, and the image that
I have is that
we're all like icebergs.
Right?
If each person is like an
iceberg, and we have the,
there's the water line, and
usually there's an awful lot
for us going on beneath
the surface.
Beneath the surface of the water
is where the real stuff
is happening in us.
So like, right now beneath the
water line for me is I'm
excited, and I'm nervous.
I see, one person just
got up to leave, and
I'm like oh my god.
He doesn't like what--
so there's that.
And just I'm kind of wondering
in myself, how's it going?
What do I want to do?
How is this all being
received?
And at the same time, I feel
the paradoxes in myself.
I feel my own confidence, my own
questioning, my sense of
that there's all the time
in the world right now.
I feel spacious.
And I feel like, oh my god,
it's almost 1:30.
There's three minutes left.
So these are just some things
that are coming up
for me right now.
So what I want everyone to do,
if you're willing to go along,
I hope you'll be willing to go
along-- stay with me for a few
more minutes, to find a partner
and just have a brief
conversation with your partner
about these two topics.
One, what's happening for you
right now below the surface,
beneath the water line.
What feelings, what thoughts,
what images are coming up for
you right now.
And the other is just say a few
words that might describe
you as a paradox.
In what way, talk about a few
things in your own life, and
your own being, that come
up for you right now as
paradoxical.
OK?
So just turn to the person
next to you, if there's
someone next to you.
If there's not, feel
free to stand up.
And just for a few minutes have
this conversation with
your partner.
[GROUP DISCUSSIONS]
[BELL CHIME]
So if you can finish
up, thank your
partner, and come on back.
I just want to read one thing,
and then I'm interested to
hear how that was and if
there's any questions.
It seems at times as though we
have no choice but to act as
though the world is permanent,
solid and predictable.
And at the same time we must
realize that everything around
us is impermanent, fluid,
and unpredictable.
If we go too far toward
believing in permanence, we'll
be thrown when something
unexpected happens.
If we lean too far toward a
belief in impermanence, we may
fall into the trap of not
setting clear goals, not
achieving what is within our
potential, and living
irresponsibly.
This can be a way of trying
to protect ourselves from
failure, or sometimes of trying
to protect ourselves
from success.
The secret of successful
business practice and life
practice is finding the balance
between control and
letting go.
It's understanding that though
little is within our control,
we must act with complete
responsibility.
In one of his talks Shunryu
Suzuki, who was the founder of
the San Francisco Zen Center,
said the secret is just to say
yes and jump off from here.
Then there is no problem.
It means to be yourself
in the present moment.
Always yourself.
Without sticking to an old self,
you forget yourself and
are refreshed.
This short, pithy, four-line
story points to the dilemma
that we all have, that we all
face, all experience.
How do we balance all of these
seemingly impossible demands
and priorities?
How can I be happy, feel safe,
be satisfied, provide for
myself and family,
and help others?
What is this life?
What does it mean to be an
authentic human being in the
realm of family, work, smart
phones, relationships, love,
hate, birth, and death?
We're all perched on the
top of a 100-foot pole.
This is a famous Zen story.
We're all perched on the
top of a 100-foot pole.
Together.
It is a very wide pole,
so wide there's no
place to fall off.
Just say yes.
MALE SPEAKER 1: Yes.
MARC LESSER: Excellent.
[LAUGHTER]
Are there --
well, first of all,
I'm interested.
How was it having those
conversations about looking
beneath the surface and
yourself as a paradox?
And are there any questions or
comments about anything?
MALE SPEAKER 2: So in talking
about paradox and what's
arising right now, one of the
questions we talked about was
if, as they say, the heart of
true practice is beyond words,
then why do we all feel
compelled to come here today
and listen to you
talk about it?
MARC LESSER: Well this is
actually very close to, I
started my talk by talking
about Dogen.
And it was said that one of
the things that drove him,
over and over again, to practice
was the question if
we all inherently have Buddha
nature, if we all are perfect
just the way we are, why
do we need to practice?
And in some way I think your
question is the same question.
Right?
We all know that we don't
need words and letters.
We have a kind of amazing,
innate understanding already,
innate intuition about--
it's all there.
And we all need a
lot of practice.
Again it reminds me of this
famous Suzuki Roshi quote,
where this was something he
said, I think this was during
a long sitting where he looked
out at his audience and said
"you're all perfect just as
you are, and you can use a
little improvement." So I think
we come here together to
both sit and feel our own
perfection, and at the same
time these words help us to fill
in these creative gaps.
So I think there's that sense
of perfection, and there's a
sense of these creative gaps.
Another place these creative
gaps show up a lot, which I
didn't say, is just in our
day-to-day habits.
Our own habitual reactions
to things.
So a creative gap that I feel,
and I think a lot of us feel,
is wanting to feel more and more
a sense of freedom, more
and more sense of less
self-consciousness.
So in a way this book, know
yourself, the forget yourself
part has a few different
elements to it.
It has a compassion
element to it.
A listening to others
A helping others.
But I think at its heart, the
other level of meaning it has,
is to be able to find a kind
of freedom where we can be
less and less self-conscious,
and more and more free and
trusting of ourselves
and of our life.
That's why we, that's why
we need all these words.
Thank you.
Other questions or comments?
NICK: I have a question.
This is Nick on VC.
MARC LESSER: Yes.
NICK: Can you hear
me all right?
MARC LESSER: I can hear you.
NICK: Great talk.
Thank you.
My question is in terms
of creative gaps.
For those of us who really
aren't sure where we want to
be, what are some good questions
that we could ask
ourselves to better
define that?
MARC LESSER: Great question.
I think this is one of the
things that in the program
here, Search Inside Yourself,
we do a lot of different
explorations around that.
One is the third of the five
emotional intelligence pieces,
is called motivation.
So you can do a lot of different
explorations around
better understanding your
own motivation.
So we do an exercise
around envisioning.
We do something around
alignment.
So you can look at, you can
start with alignment--
is a great place to start.
To be asking yourself, and
asking yourself and having
conversations with others around
things like what really
is important to you?
What are your values?
What matters?
And in what way is what you're
doing now and it's your life
now in alignment with those
values, with those things that
are important.
Just digging down there.
In a way, meditation practice is
about being so quiet and so
still that your true motivation
starts to arise.
What's really important to
you starts to come up.
You start to pay attention to
your feelings, to your voice,
to your body.
So it's mostly about
all kinds of ways
of paying more attention.
Through alignment, through
meditation practice, through
journaling and asking
yourself about--
we do an envisioning exercise
in which we envision if
everything in your life went
exactly as you want it to go,
what would your life
look like now?
In three years?
Or in five years?
This is another exercise.
So those are just some
ideas to that.
But read Meng's book, "Search
Inside Yourself," and it has
many answers to that.
And my book also has many
questions and answers around
that topic.
Thank you.
Other questions or comments?
I'm curious too.
What was it like to describe
yourself as a paradox, or to
dip down beneath the surface?
Did anyone feel some real
connection and intimacy with
this other person that was
a little surprising?
Right here in the middle
of a Google-y Monday?
[INAUDIBLE]
So you, so your comment was
you were surprised at the
commonality of the way your
partner described herself or
himself as a paradox.
And you always thought
it was just you.
I've noticed that whole--
it's one of the really wonderful
things about having
real conversations
with people.
So that would be--
One of things that I talk
about in the book is
recommending a personal audit.
Actually, so it's one thing to
say start where you are or
accepting what is.
But it's interesting actually
to start with
what actually is.
And one of the-- there's what
I think of as the things we
all know and maybe some of us
do or don't do, which is
things like getting
enough sleep,
exercise, eating good food.
But I think the kind of food
that I think may be one of the
most important foods is our
relationships, and the level
of openness and intimacy
in our relationships.
So one of the things you might
do in a personal audit is
start to keep track of how many
real conversations do you
have with someone
during the day.
Just notice.
And you can define a real
conversation maybe as where
you or someone else actually
expressed some emotion, and
there might have been
some emotional
connection with people.
And just start to, just maybe
for a week, start to jot down
at the end of each day how many
real conversations, how
many intimate conversations
did I have during the day.
For some people, I think--
it's interesting this is
partly a gender thing.
I think women tend to talk a lot
more about their feelings
and emotions, and men tend to
talk a lot less about feelings
and emotions.
That's just a generalization
which isn't 100 percent true.
But wherever you are, man or
woman, just notice where are
you on that scale, and how
might it be beneficial to
shift that needle in terms of
having the right amount of
intimate, real conversations
during your day.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: In an
environment like this in here,
where a lot of people are,
let's call it black and
white-- this is the right thing
to do; this is the wrong
thing to do.
This is the right thing,
I have to do
to climb the ladder.
What do you recommend?
How can we--
what are the pieces we can
contribute for people to
embrace the gray area and the
growth and the tension in our
day-to-day [INAUDIBLE]
MARC LESSER: Yeah.
Well I think, especially in this
kind of environment and
in a lot of business
environments, we want things
to be clear.
Right?
We want clarity.
We want that sense of ladder.
And I think we should spend as
much time as it takes to get
that clear.
But I think to be successful,
to really be successful and
happy, both in this environment
or pretty much any
environment, it's about
resilience and how we adapt.
The business model here
for, there's so much
change right here.
It's announced Google
Reader, gone.
[LAUGHTER]
This might be a sore point.
I miss Google Reader,
but I get it, right?
Because in my own company, you
have to make decisions.
And not everyone's going to be--
it's hard being a leader.
It's hard being a manager.
You see as clearly as you can,
and then you know that there's
a lot of things you
don't know.
Who knew what would happen when
you make an announcement
about Google Reader.
Who knew?
Or who knew when Netflix
announced that they were
changing their whole
pricing scheme?
And I think we're constantly,
whether it's out there
experimenting with products and
services, and within our
team, we're constantly, I think,
trying to get more
understanding of who are these
other people on the team?
One of the things we teach in
Search Inside Yourself is a
political awareness.
How does power work?
How does power and decision
making work in this
organization?
And it's often pretty complex
and not so clear, so to be
able to have a sense of clarity
and at the same time
to be adaptive and resilient.
And that also means being
willing to look stupid.
Being willing to fail.
All right.
So I think, again this is
one of those paradoxes.
The more we hold
on, the more--
So it's a little bit like, as I
was describing my drive down
here, I think it was my--
if I look underneath, it was
I wanted to be successful.
I wanted to be the
best presenter.
I wanted to get all fives.
I don't want anyone seeing
that I'm not perfect.
I think we all have
those feelings.
And I think those get in the
way of our resilience and
adaptiveness, and being able
to course in a much fuller,
adaptive, resilient,
free world.
So thank you for asking that.
Thank you all very much.
Really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
CHADE-MENG TAN: So as you can
see, Marc Lesser is a
combination of profound Zen
wisdom and getting things done
in the business world.
And for that we are
now business--
in a way we're partners now.
We are partners in crime.
Because Search Inside Yourself
has been taken out, with the
blessing of Google.
We founded an institute called
Search Inside Yourself
Leadership Institute,
S-I-Y-L-I, SIYLI.
And Marc is the CEO of SIYLI--
the SIYLI boss.
MARC LESSER: I get a big kick
of saying I'm the CEO of
silly, and my business partner
is Google's jolly good fellow.
What could be better
than that?
CHADE-MENG TAN: What could
possibly go wrong?
"Know Yourself, Forget
Yourself," available where
books are sold, and my dear
friend Marc Lesser.
[APPLAUSE]